le festival de cannes avec actuellement
la cérémonie de clôture on se prit à
décerner dont la palme d'or pour une
sélection jugée difficile les grands
favoris ne font pas partie des lauréats
le choix du jury est plutôt déconcertant
abdelah mostefa la robe est terne
le décor a le goût du carton pâte monica
bellucci maîtresse de cérémonie pour un
drôle de millésimes
beaucoup attendent et nicole kidman et
la revente pire pour d'autres villes si
l'américain gus van sant qui décroche le
prix de la mise en scène et la palme
d'or avec elephant
c'est incroyable j'étais années que
j'essaie d'avoir un film sélectionné à
cannes est là d'abord ça réconforte
elefant inspiré de la tragédie de
columbine c'est la chronique d'un lycée
ordinaire qui bascule dans le fait
divers
surprise au camp prix du jury qui va au
film usa culture occitane un réalisateur
comblé puisqu'il repart en plus avec le
prix d'interprétation masculine pour le
prix d'interprétation féminine
un homme sur scène le réalisateur denys
arcand obligé de chercher le prix de
s'excuser auprès de philippe noiret de
l'absence de la comédienne marie josée
croze
côté français c'est comme l'an passé
malgré cinq films en compétition on
repart bredouille